bird watcher christian cooper he penned
a new comic book partly inspired by
incidents of racial bias including one
involving him sir i'm asking you to stop
recording
please don't come close to me please
take your photo please don't come close
to me
please please call the cops please call
the cops
i'm going to tell them there's an
african-american man threatening my life
please tell them whatever you like
gives me chills looking at it this is
from memorial day when christian cooper
recorded
when christian cooper recorded his
widely shared confrontation with a woman
her name
is amy cooper in new york central park
now no relations he says he asked her to
follow the rules and put her dog on a
leash
and she did not as you see want to do
that since then she has apologized
on the same day in minneapolis george
floyd died after a police officer put
his knee on floyd's neck for eight
minutes
and 46 seconds christian cooper's new
comic book is called
it's a bird it follows a black teen bird
watcher named jules
who has given binoculars and they've got
special powers for this story
cooper says he was influenced by many
black americans experiences with racial
bias and injustice
and he's here this morning for an
interview that you'll see only
on cbs this morning christian cooper
it's very good to see you
i want to know a bit of the backstory dc
comics reached out to you
and you have some training in comic
books we should say so it wasn't out of
the blue
they reach out to you what was their
pitch to you and did you like it right
away
well they asked me if i wanted to share
some of my experiences
and i thought well gosh in the context
of superhero comics i'm not sure how you
do that and
they had one thing which was the title
it's a bird
and it took me a second i had to think
about it i'm like oh yeah of course
superman it's a look up in the sky it's
a plant it's a bird it's a plane
so once i heard that the story just kind
of poured out of me i just it just kind
of fell into place in my head
so so what flowed out of you because
number one we should say the
illustrations in this comic book we've
all read it are spectacular yes
they're really they they they just
conjure up such emotions so
when jules looks in the binoculars what
does he see what was your conceit here
well the the conceit is is that he gets
a pair of binoculars
uh inherited um from his grandfather who
was a
civil rights activist and korean war vet
and he thinks our
crappy old pair of binoculars and
doesn't want to deal with it
but when he starts looking through them
he sees not only the birds but he starts
seeing
these um african-americans who have been
unjustly killed at the hands of police
and he doesn't understand what he's
seeing at first and it's in the course
of the story how
he goes from being this flipping
teenager to a very sober young man who
who starts to appreciate what's been
going on
and so that that's the conceit of the
story but the idea is to weave together
all these different experiences you know
experiences i've had experiences
that others have had the experiences
we've all seen over the summer and
before
of african americans who have lost their
lives and by
transcending the specifics of any of
those individual moments
getting to the heart of the matter you
know what's going on here which is the
systemic bias
that that pervades all these incidents
christian you've made a
there's a quote that i read of yours
which i find very powerful which is that
people have to stop othering each other
what do you mean
well we have to recognize when we're
looking at something else that we're
looking at somebody's
uh somebody's brother somebody's sister
somebody's father somebody's mother you
know somebody's uncle cousin whatever
you know that
we're not looking at a thug we're not
you know we shouldn't presume that
someone is a criminal
um and i think that's very important i
think that's that's
what's what has the potential to save us
as a
society at this moment when we're so
divided
yeah christian uh tony decouple here you
don't have to convince me about the
power of a comic book and why it's a
great vehicle for a story like this but
for people who might be surprised that
it's in comic book form
i'd love to hear you talk about why a
comic book works
oh we lost him for a moment i think well
he dropped his ifb
yeah so it says to put it back in his
ear the earpiece just dropped out
all right and we saw yeah you can hear
us now christian okay here we go so i
was asking about the power of a comic
book in particular that form to tell a
story like this could you talk about
why you like it as a genre sure um
the power of comics and mark morale is
the anchor on this story
and i want to give a shout out to lethal
martinez
but mark morales said it best he said
you know comic books combine
both the pictures the images and
words so you get the power of both in
one place
and i think that visual storytelling and
sequential story
storytelling um with words and pictures
just has a power that no other medium
really has
yeah in it jules has an encounter with a
woman named beth cooper in central park
with her dog and you know jewelers her
name's not
okay okay you're right you're right
sorry sorry sorry sorry chris sorry
he has an encounter with a woman named
beth and you want to be very clear that
it's not amy cooper but
who does she represent i know my bad
what does she represent
well i mean you know obviously it's
inspired by you know
that experience but also other
experiences um she represents
she doesn't represent any one person or
any one thing
um you know that's a pastiche of a lot
of encounters i've had
and encounters that other people have
had um so
i don't know that she she represents a
she doesn't represent a particular
person um but
she represents sort of someone who's
mired
in that bias and doesn't recognize it
have you and amy cooper spoken since
that day
spoken or talked no no
any desire to do so um
i i don't see the point i'm i'm not
looking for a jerry springer moment
where you know or a hair pulling fight
or you know
a feel-good hug it out moment which has
no you know substance or meaning behind
it
so you know what i'm really about is is
sort of moving the conversation forward
yeah and if if there was a way that the
two of us getting together would do that
sure i'd be all for that but you'd have
a hard time convincing me that it
wouldn't turn into you know a sideshow a
spectacle just for
you know people to pat themselves on the
back that's that doesn't serve anybody
i think it's really focused on go ahead
go ahead
well i was just going to say what i'm
really focused on is you know
let's not get distracted there are a lot
of people who have a vested interest
right now in distracting us
from tackling the systemic bias you know
whether it's a couple of wild
individuals who want to throw bricks
through windows
or a couple of right-wing individuals
want to dress up like left-wing
individuals and throw bricks through
windows
disturb trouble that they can then use
their guns to shoot at
you know or whether it's some charlatan
in a high place who wants to
distract us from his many many failures
a lot of people have a vested interest
in distracting us right now
one thing and the point is don't be
distracted focus on this issue
just as jules does when he turns away
from that person who's trying to make it
all about her
and he focuses on those people and
that's the point focus on those we have
lost and how we keep from losing any
more
it's so well said but the thing that
struck me about the comic book chris is
that jules wears glasses
why was that important to you do your
demonstration what you said about
glasses i
i never thought of it until you pointed
it out one day
yeah you know you you mentioned this
before and it's true
i i mean there's a reason why i wear
little round glasses besides the fact
that i need them to see but i've never
gone to contact lenses because people
react very differently
to a black man wearing these and a black
man
like this and that's one of the sad
comments on
our society and you know how do we start
to fix that that's what we need to get
at
well we all thoroughly thoroughly
enjoyed it's a bird on a scale of one to
ten
we give it a 10 plus thank you chris
cooper
really good to see you job well done
it's a bird is available for free
on readdc.com and other digital
platforms